[Applause]
hey everyone I'm ash Crossan and I'm
Desiree Murphy and we have spent our
entire day
dissecting stranger things season 2 the
trailer dropped this morning yes it's
the second and final trailer before we
see all of season 2 unmet flicks on
October 27 and we have been dissecting
and we have put together a theory that
is going to blow your mind oh my gosh
okay so this is called the these'll
Hydra theory it's been circulating
around reddit for a while now and people
have kind of been theorizing it since
the end of season 1 but now that this
trailers dropped we put together every
single clue possible yeah and we have a
feeling we may have figured out all of
seasons - yeah we want you guys to take
a look at the scene from season 1
episode 8 it's one of the last scenes in
season 1 and then we're gonna break down
the these'll hydra theater all of it
something is coming something angry
hungry for your blood
it is almost here what is it that's a
Hydra I'm telling you it's not the
Dessel Hydra I'm telling you it's the
these' Hydra special Hydra oh damn it
your roars in anger will your action
what should I do
fireball him fireball the son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's a big ball it crumbles to the
ground it's gone and reaches for you one
last time
[Applause]
it doesn't places them to his
bagofholding you carry the heads out of
the dungeon victorious and you present
them the King Tristan he thanks you for
your bravery and sir whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa that's not it is it no there's
a medal sir Oh a medal ceremony what are
you talking about man the campaign was
way too short yeah it was ten-hour but
it doesn't make any sense
it makes sense oh no what about the last
night and the proud princess and those
weird flowers in the caves
I would always jeez what's that smell
you guys been playing games all day just
fighting oh this is dusty party dusty
party okay so basically what you saw is
all of the kids playing the Dungeons and
Dragons fantasy role-playing game mm-hmm
and what do we see in this we see the
vessel Hydra monster which is
essentially this like seven-headed Hydra
Greek mythology type monster that has
like pincers and a bunch of heads and
it's from dungeons dragons and
essentially I feel like these kids are
basically playing Jumanji because every
time they go to play Dungeons & Dragons
something horrible happens something
horrible happens so if you took a look
at the season 2 trailer I mean it really
aligns with this scene the parallels to
the scene specifically are really crazy
so we're gonna break it down piece by
piece something is coming something
angry hungry for your blood
it is almost here don't know something
looks here so obviously the parallel
there they both say it's almost here and
we also see the shadow monster which is
like resembling a Hydra if you look at
the Hydra look at the shadow monster
especially once you kind of look into
what the vessel Hydra is in the Dungeons
& Dragons game it has pincers that it as
its tail then it can reach out and grab
and like put things into its mouth and
that kind of claw that we saw resembles
that it's insane and get this so in
Greek mythology a Hydra it can have
anywhere from 8 to 60 heads and as long
as one
is still on it can come back to life so
basically it's unkillable if it still
has a head so you chop the head off it
can still live and it was Hercules as a
nephew that actually found the solution
that if you burn the neck before the
head comes back then it will be gone
forever
okay remember this information because I
want you come back through your best of
art dice basically the way you kill it
by burning it is it all comes down to
teamwork you can't do this on your own
which is exactly what the kids are doing
anyone knows you destroy the stick so in
the season 2 trailer we also see the
kids at one point kind of rolling these
barrels which we think maybe might have
oil in them they look like they're oil
barrels which would of course be able to
start a fire which should be the
fireball that kills the these'll Hydra
and it's interesting because they say in
the season 2 trailer if anyone knows how
to kill it it's will yeah and will is
the one that rolls the dice and actually
what has happened as they're playing the
game so I mean right on right on right
on
yes because as soon as I went back and
watch this I was like that is the claw
that yeah just out one last time and I
think this is what started our entire
deep dive today is the claw to the point
and like if this isn't the theory and
we're not proving it like I don't know
what this is if it doesn't happen it's
the duffer brothers playing with us
because then also in the trailer hopper
says something like that it's reaching
into Hawkins or hu Gaza Hawkins so and
interestingly enough we also did a deep
dive of the soundtrack for season 2 and
I feel like there's a lot in there
that's telling on its own I mean the
titles they say a lot track 13 birth /
rescue track 21 she wants me to find her
track 25 to turn track 28 connect the
dots yeah probably when they figure out
oh my gosh we did not kill the these'll
hydrate yeah and they bring it back all
to the game like oh my gosh we've been
in living in this Dungeons & Dragons
game the entire time it's you module
stop
dragons oh no what about the last night
and the proud princess and those weird
flowers in the caves okay so this this
was part two of my shift this was when
they said the flowers and the cave
because in the trailer we see at the end
of this is literally holding flowers and
we caught it early see them in a cave
mm-hmm it's perfect it blew our minds
the only unanswered questions we have
are who are the last night and the proud
princess and we do have a little bit of
a theory on who the last night would be
if you wanna get started kick this off
originally they gave us these episode
titles and episode 9 was titled belongs
with ruther but then the other day they
came out with the episode titles and
we're like water totally they were just
like Oh some weird misdirect or I don't
know what happened but my theory is that
since they are playing Dungeons and
Dragons and they're all these kind of
knights that 11 is the lost man yeah I
don't think she's the proud princess I
think she is the last night and I'm with
you there I wasn't sure at first but
after taking a second look at this like
Finn Wolf's heart has said in interviews
he's used the word lost describing his
relationship and how it changes with the
kids this season and my character is
sort of kind of a loner he doesn't
really have anyone who impressed me
whereas he doesn't have a friend to look
for and of course he was interested in
the leaven as we saw in the first yeah
oh she is kind of gone from their little
world hopper no and they don't so I
could totally see that being a reference
I think she's the last night but who is
the proud princess the only thing we
can't figure I think the natural guess
would be Nancy but I for some reason
that doesn't click yeah I also think it
could be the new characters I think
would be Sadie's sake she's like the new
redhead kind of tomboy a girl that teams
up with them we see her rolling the
barrels and we think what is a Dustin
and Lucas yeah they're gonna be
interested with her in a way interested
in her I mean aren't we all in love with
her she's adorable she's adorable so I
guess that's like our unanswered
question and what we want to know from
you guys is who you think the last night
and the proud princess are or not before
you agree with what we're saying Yuri
are you shook at the fort or do you
think that we are just being bananas
because it is a Friday when we shop us
and so we might be a little delirious
we might be upside down right now that
we on the upside down yeah
but please let us know your thoughts
yeah let us know you can tweet us you
can leave them in the comments I am so
excited for the show to come back like
so soon oh my gosh as soon as that
trailer dropped I was just like I know
we've been waiting so long feels like
forever
justice for barb is gonna happen it is
we love you Shannon I'll see you guys
next time